Merhaba sevgili öğrenciler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. Bu dersimizde 9. sınıfın 3.
ünitesi olan personal life yani kişisel
hayat adlı üniteyi hep birlikte
işleyeceğiz. Eğer bu ünite ile ilgili
alıştırmalar, testler, denemeler çözmek
istiyorsanız, öğrendiğiniz konularla
ilgili oyunlar oynamak istiyorsanız Play
Store ve App Store'dan Justin Academi
uygulamasını ücretsiz bir şekilde
indirip kullanabilirsiniz.
Kalem ve kağıdınız hazırsa dersimize
başlıyoruz. Bu ünitede insanların dış
görünüşlerini yani fiziksel
özelliklerini anlatırken
kullanabileceğimiz ifadeleri
öğreneceğiz. Physical appearance,
fiziksel dış görünüş. İnsanların dış
görünüşlerinden bahsederken şu
kelimeleri kullanabiliriz.
Attractive, çekici.
Young, genç.
Old, yaşlı.
Middle age, orta yaşlı.
Beautiful. Güzel.
Oversized. Büyük boy kocaman.
Charismatic
karizmatik.
Handsome yakışıklı
cute tatlı.
Body weight and hide. Şimdiki başlıkta
ise vücudumuzun uzunluklarını ve
ağırlıklarını anlatan kelimeleri
öğreneceğiz.
Wellbu kaslı.
Skinny sıska cılız.
Plum şişman
slim thin. Zayıf
medium height orta boylu.
Tall uzun.
Sırada ten renkleri ile ilgili kelimeler
var. Skin color. Ten renkleri.
Brunet. Esmer.
Fair
açık tent skin
bronz ten pale solgun
dark skin koiten. Hair color shape
saçların renkleri ve şekilleri.
Curly kıvırcık
wavy dalgalı
straight düz.
Blond sarı.
Ginger kızıl
fair kumral
black hair siyah saç
brown hair kahverengi saç
shoulder length omuz boy.
Bold kel. İnsanların saçlarını
anlatırken renginden, boyundan ve
şeklinden bahsederiz. Ama bunları
anlatırken rastgele kafamıza göre
kelimeleri yan yana sıralayıp
kullanamayız. Bunları yaparken belli bir
sırayı takip etmemiz gerekiyor.
Saçlarımızdan bahsederken öncelikle
saçın uzunluğunu yani length dediğimiz
kısmı anlatacağız. Uzun mu, kısa mı,
orta boy mu, omuz boy mu? Bundan
bahsetmemiz gerekiyor. İkinci olarak
saçların şeklinden bahsedeceğiz. Düz mü,
kıvırcık mı ya da dalgalı mı? Bunu
söylememiz gerekiyor. Ve son olarak
saçın renginden bahsedeceğiz. Bu sırayı
takip ederek saçlarla ilgili cümleler
oluşturabiliriz. Örnekleri inceleyelim.
She has short curly black hair. Onun
kısa, kıvırcık siyah saçları vardır.
Gördüğünüz gibi short kısa diyerek saçın
boyunu anlattık. Curly kıvırcık diyerek
saçın şeklinden bahsettik. Ve son olarak
black siyah diyereksee renginden
bahsettik. Bu sırayı takip etmemiz
gerekiyor. I have got short straight
blond hair. Benim kısa düz sarı saçlarım
vardır. Önce boyunu, sonra şeklini ve en
son olarak rengini anlattık. Iyice
gözler demektir. Sırada gözleri anlatan
kelimeler var.
Hazel, ela göz, blue eyes, mavi göz,
green eyes, yeşil göz.
Saçlarımızdan ve gözlerimizden
bahsederken her zaman karşınıza çıkacak
olan kalıp have got ve has got
ifadeleridir. Bunlar bir şeye sahip
olmak anlamına gelir. Bunları dikkatli
bir şekilde dinleyin çünkü İngilizcenin
temel konularından bir tanesidir ve
kullanım oldukça kolaydır. Bu ünitede
ise saçlardan ve gözlerden bahsederken
bol kullanacağız. Öncelikle pozitif yani
olumlu hallerini birlikte inceleyelim.
Kullanımları kolaydır ama
kullanıldıkları özneler farklıdır. Yani
dikkat edeceğiniz şey öznelerdir. I, we,
you ve they özneleri ile birlikte have
got kullanılır. I, ben demek, we, biz,
you, sen, siz, they onlar. Eğer
bunlardan bahsedeceksek sahiplik anlamı
katmak için have got kullanırız.
Kısacası have olarak da görebilirsiniz.
Bir tane örnek inceleyelim. I have got
green eyes. Ben yeşil gözlere sahibim.
Benim yeşil gözlerim var. Geri kalan
öznelerde yani he, she ve it öznelerinde
has got kullanılır. Kısacası has olarak
da görmeniz mümkündür. She has got two
cats. Onun iki tane kedisi var. O iki
tane kediye sahiptir.
Negative form olumsuz hal demektir. Eğer
bu sahiplik bildiren have got ve has
gotı olumsuz olarak kullanacaksak yine
öznelere dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor. I,
we, you ve they öznelerinden sonra have
got olumsuz olarak haven't got şeklinde
kullanılır. We haven't got a car. Bizim
bir arabamız yok. Biz bir arabaya sahip
değiliz. Geri kalan öznelerde ise yani
he, she ve it öznelerinde ise has got,
hasn't got olarak kullanılır. Örneği
inceleyelim. He hasn't got blue eyes.
Onun mavi gözleri yoktur. O mavi gözlere
sahip değildir. Eğer buitede saçlardan
ve gözlerden bahsedeceksek bu kalıpları
bilmemiz gerekiyor. İnsanların dış
görünüşlerini yani fiziksel
özelliklerini sorarken what does she
look like sorusunu kullanırız. Dikkat
ederseniz sorunun sonunda look like
ifadesi var. Bu insanların dış
görünüşünü sorarken kullandığımız
ifadedir. Cevap verirken öğrendiğimiz
kelimelerle ilgili cümleler kuracağız.
She has got long, straight, black hair
and blue eyes. O uzun, düz, siyah
saçlara ve mavi gözlere sahiptir. What
does he look like? Onun dış görünüşü
nasıldır? He is tallim. O uzun ve
zayıftır. He has got short curly blond
hair and green eyes. Onun kısa, kıvırcık
sarı saçları ve yeşil gözleri vardır.
What does Ayşe look like? Ayşe'nin dış
görünüşü nasıldır? Look like ifadesi
insanın dış görünüşünü sorar. Ayşe is
short and fat. Ayşe kısa ve kiloludur.
To ve enough kalıpları bu ünitede yine
bol bol karşınıza çıkacak. to bir şeyin
aşırı gereğinden fazla olduğu anlamına
gelir ve olumsuz bir anlam taşır.
Örneğin it is too hot to go out. Dışarı
çıkamayacak kadar hava sıcak. Gördüğünüz
gibi to burada çok anlamına gelir ama
olumsuz bir anlam taşır. He is too young
to drive a car. O araba sürmek için
oldukça fazlasıyla genç. Enough ise bir
şeyin yeterli olduğunu anlatır. The
dress is long enough to wear. Elbise
giyilecek kadar uzun. I not patient
enough. Ben yeterince sabırlı değilim.
Eğer to ve enough'la karşılaşırsanız
artık nasıl kullanacağınızı
biliyorsunuz. To'nun olumsuz olduğunu
unutmayalım. İnsanların dış
görünüşlerini nasıl anlatacağımızı
öğrendik. Eğer birinin fiziksel
özelliklerinden bahsetmek istiyorsak
artık bunu rahatlıkla yapabiliriz.
Şimdiki konu ise personality yani
kişisel özellikler, karakter
özellikleri. Eğer karşımızdaki insanın
kişiliğinden, karakterinden
bahsedeceksek bu kelimeleri bilmemiz
gerekiyor.
Carelesseless,
umursamaz, dikkatsiz.
Serious, ciddi.
Confident, kendine güvenen.
Honest, dürüst.
Kind, kibar.
Friendly, arkadaş canlısı.
Cheerful neşeli.
C sakin.
Gentle nazik.
Rud kaba.
Smart akıllı.
Outging dışa dönük.
Moody karamsar.
Peaceful. Huzurlu.
Forgetful, unutkan.
Clever, zeki.
Funny, komik.
Shy, utangaç.
Lovely, sevimli.
Helpful, yardımsever.
Genuine, eşsiz.
Successful.
Başarılı.
Quiet, sessiz.
İnsanların kişisel özelliklerini yani
karakterlerini anlatan kelimeleri
öğrendik. Eğer bir insanın kişisel
özellikleri ile ilgili soru soracaksak
"What is he like?" sorusunu kullanırız.
Dikkat ederseniz bu kez sorunun sonu
sadece like ile bitiyor. What is he
like? Onun kişisel özelliği nasıldır? He
is brave and kind. O cesur ve kibardır.
What type of person is she? O ne tür bir
kişiliğe sahiptir? She is outgoing and
friendly. O dışa dönük ve arkadaş
canlısıdır. What does she like? Onun
kişisel özelliği yani karakteri
nasıldır? She is honest cheerful. O
dürüst ve neşelidir.